now Silver State Schools Credit Union
appreciates all Educators and they want
to say thank you Mercedes spoke to
president and Scott A.R kills about the
exciting things they're doing for
Teacher Appreciation Week
welcome back to the show Scott it's
great to have you thank you Mercedes I
appreciate it I am so excited because it
is one of my favorite weeks of the Year
teacher appreciation week and Silver
State Schools Credit Union they have
strong ties to education in this
community and I'm guessing you probably
have something pretty good happening
absolutely Mercedes so Silver State
Schools Credit Union was founded by
Educators and many of our members are
Educators so we do have something
special for the teacher appreciation
week you know um to honor our teachers
and show them the appreciation we're
actually giving away four 500 gift cards
and all teachers in southern Nevada are
eligible to enter the drawing and they
do not need to be a member to be
eligible to eligible to win however we
would love it if they do have a
membership here that's great so is this
something where I can enter my
daughter's favorite teachers or do the
teachers have to enter themselves
that's a great question Mercedes and yes
you or anyone in the community can
actually nominate a teacher and by the
way teachers also can nominate
themselves so entries are accepted now
through Friday May 12th and for details
and and to enter the drawing just visit
silverstatecu.com
teacher week I love how generous you are
to the teachers I was wondering not
putting any pressure on you here but
what about employees who work in the
education field that are not necessarily
teachers some of the support staff do
you have any special offers for them
yeah I'm really glad you asked because
that's that's something that we always
want to make sure that we do is is it's
not just teachers it's support staff and
everybody that's in the education field
and so so Silver State Schools Credit
Union has actually partnered with Jim
Marsh to provide all Educational
Employees at any public chartered or
private school with our education or
educator appreciation month promotion
for this promotion anyone who's employed
with the education position is actually
eligible to receive up to three thousand
dollars over the Kelly Blue Book also
known as KBB value for your trade-in
um you're also eligible for first year
registration of up to 500 and uh and at
this time of year I think it's a nice
kick or two to have 90 days to first
payment and that's if you purchase a
vehicle from Jim Marsh Kia and then
Finance it through sulfur State Schools
Credit Union in addition the credit
union is providing all Educational
Employees believe it or not with a half
percent discount so that's 0.50 discount
for this promotion off of the normal
rate all loans are subject to approval
and this offer is available from May 1st
through May 31st and complete details
are available by visiting
silverstatecu.com I love the partnership
I love what you do for our Educators I
love being a member of Silver State
Schools Credit again thank you so much
for coming back on the show Scott We
Appreciate You Mercedes thank you
thank you again to Silver State Schools
Credit Union for sponsoring that segment
call
702-733-8820 for more information or
just visit
silverstatecu.com we'll be right back